that's ten points right now for Jesus
and Tatum's add a steal to that as the
Aaron Fox comes away with it
you better call Omar because that one's
gonna be fun house a highlights
Tom Collins thrown at home we got one
minute left to that USA has been a
10-point lead one more time for your
mind he's staring
got nothing man do
her looks blaze it into tray two seconds
watch rays fluttered
[Applause]
ever
deserve it
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and getting all
the love on the sidelines no man he's
putting together a heck of a game and
the bow is bobbing back out herder got
that one short gets it back throws that
down with authority look at his dunk
here beautiful it is us the team needs
an answer some days it is get away from
the USA team right now
Estrella let's take another look from
Trey young spin around John Carlin Kevin
looking lob to the basket away
[Applause]
and twinsen in overtime but basket is
good video review off take an average
thirty six threes again here's Kevin it
is your day young man Collins on the
handoff Troy gives it back
[Applause]
look at this lob right on time and right
on target Conley six seconds five
beverage moves it up spins in corners
dre beats the buzzer and hits the
three-pointer
[Music]
bleep driving Beverly giving fumbled
away picked up by Spellman linking out
Kevin hurt her
[Applause]
7650 eight
ray Applebaum cattle it turns it in and
gets pound a perfect pass and Collins
right there - one hand at home game
Dallas has only got one route in a
possession of all game know
how about to handle about the spin Vince
gets him a little bit of separation on
at all his sixth three-pointer of the
year driving and a deflection by hurt or
took it off the hand of Wiggins Trey
gets it ahead pays corner three and the
early off to the core Anderson
[Applause]
five incredible points that is amazing
man
you got will run more picking local
roles with white side if you don't it's
gonna be tough
oh look at Kevin and assists number ten
comes right here I mean Matt Ryan would
be thrilled to see that fan
oh is that's a pin pointer the Hawks are
pouring it on now
these are tonight comets - pepperidge
[Music]
done by John Collins five seconds for
pray over midcourt
Winslow defending weights trailing him
to he's Houdini
they heat the trap right here but
there's three guys he goes between three
and meets a fourth guy at the rim nice
little floater to get his twentieth
points Bertie bomb on the boss another
block Alec slim he's got that rep
protected the bounce
- the whole Suzy solid block spirit on
the nice bounce pass bills driven herder
which is nice talk at the rim herder
with the long lead to Collins and John
puts it in and he gets a easy look
that's seven first quarter points but
Jenkins for Dix all over if y'all get to
amp nice spin move back to his right
hand cancer a little bit too late
come on swoops in to corral the board up
it comes to hurt her Kevin to the basket
and that's a bad one
Coldplay's you saw to miss out my den
witty there Kevin hurt pushing the ball
up the floor dan genetics backpedaling
instead of planned equal to R alpha JC
Chandor chases about the bed floor Kevin
was fine for the shot clock they get
into college and the Hawks go up to 123
to 121 good defense on Kevin hurt us
close out there by Chandler's but John
Connors nice little trip and step back
muscala didn't want to foul very
reluctant to take it but he made it pray
from just inside puts it down push turn
for Jeremy
further cutting banks and scores in a
foul on Brooklyn
[Applause]
you haven't heard again another guy on
Atlanta Hawks team who's welcome nice
baseline jamming we say goodbye to Brook
Lopez on 6 pounds John Collins takes the
bump right there and this finishes at
the rim that's a good call
Ingram's lost it great picks it up leads
the break Trey it leaves it for harder
off the turnover
I step back Trey young behind the back
to Kevin Kevin murder down difficult if
not a jam for Kevin murder
Ken's notice goes up and over Wilson
Chandler is 1 for all time soon yes nice
bounce pass by deadness goes up and
rolls it down tips away but into the
hands of Trey back to college
[Applause]
yes
let's hit those two threes he is going
to be gone for a while and there's the
one hander to John Colin pickle
cherry-pick oh gee
[Applause]
so Trey Young has now dribbled between
two guys lay down by for Jimmy Butler
one defense right now back to herder 15
for Kevin the veteran point guard 31
year old DJ Augustine driving what a
block by John Collins is just a heck of
a block Shawn here you didn't see John
Collins
you know team's way
Fouts for the dump check this out and
watch Brown on this place where's oh no
wait I don't know he hadn't gone
anywhere yet he's at the rim
Derrick Desmond throwing one down
beautiful bounce pass great setups here
between the legs pass there right in
stride for Desmond for going down that
was a wonderful play there by stray
young pick-and-roll with comets but
nothing there the size of Billy out
front
and the game is tied
Kevin murder where you got moose collar
guarding have been hurt he's not gonna
he's not gonna be able to guard him off
the dribble
nice collar just a little bit too late
there
what is up and the speech to the
self-proclaimed fastest player in the
NBA
Neeraj Fox Oh baby
taking it all right
he's my sleeps in the donut sense man
I'm telling you let's take another look
at that dunk by John Collins here's a
wild stat about John Collins
he's one of nine players in the NBA to
average 19 at night Rocketman there's
our memory on the basket ray shot clock
at three platelets it's lion head set
what a rainbow three for three
shot clock winding down he just let this
one fly but again he got to watch that
right leg 32 for Kyrie Turner gets
inside today
haven't heard her with 18 Reggie Jackson
29 points 7 assists pouch to Drummond
taking it up at College denies it John
Collins right here on Drummond Bray with
7 6 trains gonna launch from deep it
looks like yep there it comes
[Applause]
in water check it out
where you gotta make them Kevin the time
again that just not good defense for a
survey is the double strain
[Applause]
timeout Minnesota
skits have out of their seats at State
Farm man would have played that Alex
went seven second six my second stray
it now goes up ladies it going that ties
the game and just weaves his way through
all those white shirts Kevin off the -
screen
beautiful but look at the set up by
Kevin her to pinpoint man he goes up and
winds it up and throws it down when I
brought me out my seats and when their
scale to 1 to 10 this dog here 10 and a
half not the guys ahead wouldn't get the
air spoons pray Allah lead pass
[Applause]
just another
that's been gifs beyond half-court right
on point maybe this is a heck of a pants
[Applause]
I saw that coming all the way laundry
mom you're very young looks to move in
lobs it hears that Trey young no-look
lob and Burt knows how to finish he goes
up high tenses it and throws it down
takeaway here Royce O'Neal latest Baylor
he was a teammate of torian's in college
[Applause]
he froze the entire interior deep back
to the jams move one more time from Trey
young you see the trap right there and
he kind of faked him out with the
dribble that's not out of his passing
ability his shooting ability and he's
and he's not just a catch and shoot guy
exactly if he could put it on the floor
yes not a good pass there to devise
Harrison here comes the Hawks and Kevin
hoodie with a nice look away and hope
Bobo I said well sure miss rebound
got it an open cut in
[Applause]
just a flat rejection that was a great
block this block here by John Collins
you should have just laid this up you
know he had time to [ __ ] it back and
thought that John Wooden gonna challenge
it's an easy block for Johnny lead with
a three and Trey as that bounds at his
step makes the
[Applause]
trae Young gets him out of their seats
one more times watch this
fakes the behind the back that goes
through his legs and drew the foul on
Collison his second they are what we
about you know and that what you strive
to be like those these type of guys to
perhaps on one date you can emulate you
can idolize and staying the course to
finish games and you know that's been
our Tilly's Hill I think we played some
very good teams and some not so good
team besides JC
not a better job of just protecting the
rim like you see JC here what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content